Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 148. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer Ausgabe, wo es mal wieder um Technik und Community gehen soll. Ein Blick in die Landschaft und zwar in eine ganz spezifische Landschaft, nämlich die Welt der Apaches. Die Apache Web-Server ist sicherlich vielen bekannt. Weniger ist bekannt, dass eigentlich hinter diesem Begriff noch sich sehr viel mehr versteckt und genau darüber möchte ich heute reden und zwar gleich mit zwei Gästen, mit Erik, Erik Abele, hallo, und mit Oswald, also known as Kai Seidler, hallo. Wir hatten ja schon mal die Ehre, haben wir gerade nachgeschlagen hier, das war Chaosradio 55, das ist schon lange her, fast zehn Jahre.
Oh, wir sind alt geworden.
Ja, aber du bist dem Chat-Thema nicht so treu geblieben.
Nee, das war damals zehn Jahre her. Ich hatte damals schon zehn Jahre den Chat-Server hier in Berlin an der FU betrieben und gemanagt und nach zehn Jahren hat es gereicht dann irgendwann und ich habe mich dann um andere Dinge gekümmert, unter anderem um den Apache Webserver und deswegen bin ich heute Abend auch hier.
Und du, Erik, du bist so als freifliessender Berater unterwegs oder wie kann man das so sehen?
Ich berate Unternehmen in allen Fragen rund um Internet-Technologien, inklusive Apache natürlich.
Und ist das eigentlich auch dein Modell oder bist du mehr ein Community?
Eigentlich sind die ganzen Apache-Geschichten, die ich zur Zeit mache, wirklich private Sachen. Also das mache ich aus privatem Interesse an der Technik, mit denen ich mich auch im professionellen Bereich beschäftige. Aber Apache Friends ist wirklich eine private Sache, wo ich sage, hier versuche ich mein Wissen, was ich professionell erworben habe, auch Einsteigern zur Verfügung zu stellen und Einsteigern zu helfen. Das ist in dem Fall eine ganz freie und ehrenamtliche Arbeit, die ich da mache.
Womit das erste Stichwort genannt wäre, Apache Friends, was ist denn das genau?
Apache Friends ist eine kleine Organisation, die ich vor acht Jahren etwa gegründet habe mit einem alten Freund von mir, Kai Vogelgesang. Und wir hatten damals, 2001 war das glaube ich, zusammen ein Buch geschrieben, Apache for Dummies, diese schönen schwarz-gelben Bücher, Diese dicken? Diese dicken und auch dünne Bücher, ja.
War das dick oder dünn?
Das war Mittel.
Mittel.
Mittel, ich weiß nicht mehr, zwei, dreihundert Seiten war es.
Okay, also gibt es schon ein paar Fragen.
Ja, und beim Schreiben dieses Buches haben wir festgestellt, dass sehr, sehr viel, wenn du so ein Buch schreibst wie Apache for Dummies, dass du dich sehr, sehr viel damit beschäftigst, wie installiere ich den Apache, wie kompile ich den Apache, wie kriege ich den Apache zum Laufen, was aber eigentlich gar nicht die Fragen sind, die wir in dem Buch großartig besprechen wollten, sondern eher, was kann ich hinterher mit dem Apache machen, wie kann ich den Apache konfigurieren und den Apache als Werkzeug einzusetzen. Und da sind wir eben beim Schreiben dieses Buches auf die Idee gekommen, eine Software zu machen und die Software heißt XAMPP. Und diese Software erleichtert es Einsteigern in diese Welt des Apaches einzutauchen, in der Form, dass es einfach gemacht wird, Apache und verwandte Technologien, kommen wir vielleicht noch zu, einfach zu installieren, um sie dann tatsächlich zu nutzen. Also es geht nicht darum, bei XAMPP oder bei Apache Friends zu sehen, wie komme ich hin, einen Apache-Webserver zu haben, sondern der Apache-Webserver ist schon da, und wie gehe ich mit diesem Webserver um. Und da ist Apache Friends und Apache Friends XAMPP unsere Art und Weise, Leuten zu helfen, in diese Welt zu kommen, diese Hürde des Installierens dieser Software möglichst gering zu halten und so einfach diese komplizierten Techniken zu nutzen. Und das ist das, was wir mit Apache Friends und Apache Friends XAMPP machen. Was heißt denn XAMPP?
Das ist bestimmt eine lustige Abkürzung.
XAMPP ist eine lustige Abkürzung. Er spielt mit der Abkürzung AMP, also Apache MySQL und PHP, oder Apache MySQL und Perl. Und XAMPP, das X steht für das Betriebssystem in dem Fall. Und es ist eben diese Kombination, das Apache MySQL, PHP und Perl für verschiedene Betriebssysteme, für Windows, für Linux, für Mac OS X und für Solaris in diesem Fall.
Also X steht sozusagen für alles.
Genau.
Nicht für Unix, weil es auf X endet, sondern Windows aber auch mit Spielen.
Nee, in diesem Fall nicht. Richtig.
Genau.
Okay. Das heißt, im Prinzip ist das Ganze so eine Community-Initiative, um quasi mangelhaftes Wissen um die ganze Plattform als solche zu bearbeiten.
Richtig.
Ja, das kann man gut sagen.
Und wie stellt sich das dann so konkret dar? Ich meine, habt ihr da irgendwie so ein Callcenter zu Hause in der Küche eingerichtet?
Also der größte Part ist einmal diese Software.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Oh Gott des Willen, ja, ich habe auch mal eine, in Deutschland ist man ja verpflichtet, seine Telefonnummer im Impressum anzugeben. Und da kommen schon manchmal ganz lustige Anrufe an dann tatsächlich. Nein, ernsthaft, das eine große, was wir machen, ist einfach das Anbieten dieser Software überhaupt. Erstmal diese Software zu haben, dass die Leute diese Technologien einfach nutzen können. Und das zweite, was wir machen, ist dann auch noch ein Forum betreiben dafür. Und in dem Forum können wir dann diese Fragen beantworten.
Wo läuft das Ganze? Und das wendet sich jetzt sozusagen an jeden, der irgendwie ein Problem hat.
Das wendet sich hauptsächlich an Einsteiger.
Das heißt, hier geht es wirklich darum, die Leute überhaupt erst mal dahin zu bringen, irgendwas zu publizieren.
Richtig, genau.
Und was, ich meine, wer kommt dann so dann auch euch zu? Ich meine, das Ganze ist ja sehr breit angelegt. Das gibt dann hier irgendwie ein X-Sprachen und Cipapó.
Ursprünglich hatten wir gedacht, eigentlich eher Entwickler anzusprechen, so dass wir gesagt haben, wir wollen Entwicklern helfen, in diese Welt zu kommen, oder Programmierern, professionellen Programmierern. Was sich gezeigt hat, ist, dass es dann aber gar nicht mal unbedingt wirklich diese Entwickler waren, die wir damit angesprochen haben, sondern ich würde mal fast sagen, der größte Teil dürften tatsächlich Grafiker oder Designer sein, die die Software nutzen, um auf einem lokalen Rechner Webseiten zu entwickeln, mehr von einem grafischen Aspekt aus, und dann vielleicht noch anzufangen, aus Grafiker-Sicht Sachen zu entwickeln, zum Beispiel PHP zu programmieren, um da ein bisschen Leben rein zu bringen in die ganze Geschichte. Und das ist mittlerweile unsere größere Zielgruppe eigentlich, also gar nicht mehr der Entwickler, sondern tatsächlich der Grafiker oder der wirklich auch Einsteiger in Programmieren.
Also schon eigentlich Entwickler, bloß nicht jetzt die etablierten Entwickler, sondern halt so, na gut, ich meine, wenn es ich eh für Einsteiger, ist wahrscheinlich nur eine andere Einsteigergruppe als gedacht.
Richtig, genau. Und dementsprechend haben diese Leute natürlich auch andere Probleme. Da geht es dann auch oft einfach wirklich tatsächlich noch ums Entwickeln, also um wie programmiere ich überhaupt. Warum, wenn wir uns dann aber in dem Fall dann nicht mehr beschäftigen. Also wir versuchen schon tatsächlich zu fokussieren auf Probleme beim Apache. Wie mache ich bestimmte Sachen mit dem Apache Web Server oder wie löse ich bestimmte Sachen in den Programmiersprachen, sei es dann eben Perl oder sei es PHP. Oder wie verbinde ich jetzt den Apache mit einem Java Application Server zum Beispiel. Das sind dann auch noch Bereiche, die wir haben. Aber sobald es dann darüber hinausgeht, sind wir eigentlich schon in Anführungszeichen nicht mehr zuständig.
Was macht man denn da so für Entdeckungen? Ich meine, Open Source Software wird ja eigentlich immer so ein bisschen als der Segen angesehen für die Gemeinde. Ganz klar, man kriegt da erstmal was kostenlos. Das kann dann auch eine ganze Menge. Andererseits ist es auch nicht unbedingt jetzt für besondere Benutzerfreundlichkeit bekannt. Ich meine, so ein komplexes Gebilde wie ein Web Server plus eine Datenbank plus ein Administrationstool, Programmiersprache etc., das ist ja schon eigentlich eine relativ komplexe Geschichte. Macht ihr denn die Erfahrung, dass man immer wieder so bei A anfangen muss oder gibt es da draußen irgendwie ein wachsendes Verständnis und wirkt sich das irgendwie auch wieder auf die Software aus?
Genau das ist, wo XAMPP ansetzt, du hast gesagt, es ist ein komplexes Gebilde und es ist tatsächlich auch ein komplexes Gebilde. Und wenn jemand versucht, diese ganzen Sachen wie Apache, MySQL, PHP und Pearl oder sonst noch irgendwelche anderen Tools zu installieren, ist es ein Ding, was ein Profi vielleicht innerhalb von einem Tag oder wenigen Stunden schafft. Ein Anfänger braucht da Wochen für und selbst dann ist er nicht unbedingt erfolgreich damit. Das heißt, es ist wirklich schwierig, solche Installationen zu machen. Und mit XAMPP ist es eben sehr, sehr einfach. In Falle zum Beispiel der Windows-Version, die gibt es als ZIP-Archiv. Das ZIP-Archiv lagert dich runter, pack es aus und starte die Software. Ich muss sie nicht mehr installieren. Es gibt auch einen Installer, mit dem ich dann arbeiten kann, aber im Prinzip funktioniert es auch mit einem einfachen ZIP-Archiv. Und das ist natürlich sehr, sehr einfach. Und damit kommen dann eben auch Einsteiger ohne wirkliche Hürden in die Lage, diese Technologien zu nutzen. Das heißt, da gibt es schon mal keine Probleme mehr mit. Der Apache läuft, die MySQL-Datenbank läuft, PHP funktioniert, Perl auch oder PHP-Admin. Das alles funktioniert sofort. Da kann es kein Problem mehr geben. Und jetzt kann ich mich als Nutzer dieser Software darum kümmern, meine tatsächliche Arbeit zu machen. Sei es eben das Gestalten von Webseiten oder sei es das Programmieren von Websites, was auch immer ich machen möchte. Darum kann ich mich jetzt kümmern. Und das ist das, was wir mit XAMPP machen, eben um das, was du eben auch schon gerade angesprochen hast, diesen komplizierten Charakter von Open Source ein bisschen zu dämpfen. Das heißt, es muss nicht kompliziert sein. Es ist meistens kompliziert, weil es meistens Techniker sind, die diese Software erstellen. Und der Techniker hat nicht unbedingt den Endanwender im Blick. Und das haben wir eben versucht, mit XAMPP jetzt oder seit knapp acht Jahren jetzt zu entschärfen und es tatsächlich dem Benutzer auch einfacher zu machen, Open Source Software zu verwenden. Und einfacher geht es nicht mehr, als wir es jetzt haben.
Der Apache Web Server ist ja jetzt keine brandneue Technologie, sondern ist irgendwie schon lange da. Das ist, glaube ich, auch immer noch der mit Abstand am weitesten verbreitete Web Server im Netz.
Das heißt, so ganz, ich glaube den Apache gibt es jetzt seit 15 Jahren vielleicht?
Ja, ursprünglich seit 15 Jahren, seit 94, 95.
Das ist schon ein bisschen.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist echt abgehangene Software, oder?
Also ich habe angefangen, habe fast der NCSA-HTTP-Dienung.
Der wurde ursprünglich 94 von der Apache Group damals noch übernommen und dann eben zum Apache Web Server weiterentwickelt bis heute.
Und irgendwie ist er ja nicht weit gekommen. Ich meine, wir sind jetzt immer noch bei Version 2.
Da sieht man mal, was gutes Software ist, oder?
Ja, wofür ist das jetzt? Also wie muss man den Apache Web Server nehmen? Ich meine, da gibt es ja verschiedenste Lager. Manche denken halt, das ist halt irgendwie einfach so ein großer Tanker, der kann zwar irgendwie alles, aber ist dann irgendwie in kritischen Fällen irgendwie nicht schnell genug oder andere meinen, der kann zwar viel, aber ist dann auch wieder so kompliziert, den Griff zu kriegen, was sind so deine Erfahrungen?
Also ich schätze den Apache Web Server eigentlich als, er ist vielleicht nicht der schlankeste auf der Welt, aber er ist eigentlich eine gute Mischung aus Funktion und trotzdem noch Performance. Also er ist kein Mammut, er ist auch kein Spatz sicherlich, aber er hat es so geschafft, trotz all der ganzen Funktionen, die er hat, trotzdem noch relativ schlank zu bleiben.
Also ein klassisches Arbeitspferd, könnte man sagen.
Er ist ein Arbeitspferd, ja, das ist sehr schön, will ich sagen.
Was muss man denn wissen über den Apache Server? Ich meine, du bist ja an der Stelle, wo die Leute mit ihren ersten Fragezeichen ankommen. Ist es schwierig bei einer Technologie, die schon so lange da ist, dass man davon ausgeht, dass sie sowieso jeder kennt, da irgendwie jetzt noch reinzufragen, was ist es denn? Was ist denn an deiner Stelle ein besonders erfolgreiches Konzept von dem Apache Webserver, was jetzt auch dazu beigetragen hat, dass es so populär ist? Oder ist es einfach nur deshalb so populär, weil es keinem anderen gelungen ist, sich mit dem Thema auseinanderzusetzen, im gleichen Maße?
Ich glaube, es gibt ja schon Konkurrenzprodukte. Ich glaube, das Geheimnis beim Apache oder des Erfolges des Apaches ist A, dass er sehr stabil ist, einfach im Betrieb stabil ist. Deshalb habe ich es noch nie erlebt, dass mir ein Apache von sich aus abgeraucht ist. Deswegen läuft das einfach. Zweitens haben die Entwickler des Apaches geschafft, auch über diese vielen, vielen Jahre von der Konfigurationsdatei relativ stabil zu bleiben. Das heißt, die Configs, die ich verwende, kann ich so weiter verwenden, zumindest über die letzten zehn, 15 Jahre kann ich die gleiche Konfiguration verwenden, ohne da groß migrieren zu müssen. Wenn ich ein Update des Apache Web-Servers mache auf einen Server, habe ich eigentlich keine Angst, dass mir irgendwas um die Ohren fliegt. Diese Stabilität ist einfach da und auch diese konstante Stabilität über die vielen, vielen Jahre ist da. Es gibt nicht alle drei Wochen eine neue Version. Ich bin nicht gezwungen, dauernd abzugraden, abzugraden, abzugraden. Zum Beispiel, was man PHP vorwerfen könnte, wenn man es wollte. Bei PHP kommen dauernd neue Versionen raus. Ich muss dauernd PHP upgraden. Ich übertreibe mit dauernd vielleicht. Dauernd ist es nicht mehr abwärtskompatibel. Ich muss meine Applikation anfassen. Ich muss irgendwas ändern. Jedes Mal, wenn ich PHP auf eine neue Major-Release upgrade, kann es sein, dass etwas nicht mehr funktioniert und das ist bei mir bei Apache nie passiert. Ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, eine gewisse Stabilität.
Ein Fels in der Brandung.
Hinzu kommt natürlich auch, dass er eigentlich überall in jedem Hosting-Environment zur Verfügung steht. Er ist seit Jahren ein absoluter Standard und du hast ihn halt überall, sei es mitgeliefert bei den meisten Linux-Distributionen oder auch bei Mac OS 10 bis hin zu den professionellen Hosting-Environments, die natürlich alle Apache und die Standard-Konfiguration anbieten.
Aber ist denn dann der Patch überhaupt für die Zukunft gerüstet? Man, es gibt ja jetzt zunehmend, im Web ändern sich die Modelle. Ja, es geht hin zu intelligenteren Clients, JavaScript spielt da eine große Rolle, viel der Logik wird in den Kleinen verlagert und es geht ja, früher war das halt immer so, naja, der Webserver, der hat die großen Dateien und der kleine, schlanke Webbrauser kommt an und er holt die sich und dann wird die dann niemals so ausgeliefert. Das ist immer so eine Anfrage, der man sich auch ein bisschen Zeit lassen kann, weil der Rest geschieht im Prinzip danach. Und jetzt haben wir aber eigentlich halt sehr viel leichtgewichtigeres Web in zunehmenden Maße, wo kleinste Nachrichten hin und her fliegen, wo man auch das Problem hat, dass man unter Umständen, ja, was heißt unter Umständen, eigentlich schon fast immer gezwungen ist, mal eben zu skalieren. Da ist man dann halt irgendwie auf Slashdot, naja, gut Slashdot spielt die Rolle nicht mehr ganz so, was weiß ich, und so ein Twitter-König wirft die eigene Webseite durch die Gegend, ja, dann ist halt die Kiste in den Knien, ja, das mag jetzt nicht unbedingt nur am Webseiter liegen, das will ich damit gar nicht sagen, da spielen auch ganz andere Sachen rein, Bandbreite und Pipapo, oder was weiß ich meine. Reagiert denn eigentlich das Apache-Projekt an der Stelle da, oder ist es eher so eine konservative Stelle, dass man sagt, das wollen wir gar nicht abdecken, sondern wir bleiben einfach hier bei unserem Grundschema?
Also, was ich gerade gesagt habe, deutet ja erstmal auf etwas sehr Konservatives hin, und das wäre auch in diesem Fall mein Eindruck, dass es da keine Versuche gibt, da gefällig zu sein oder in die Richtung zu gehen. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob man da großartig an der Technik irgendwas ändern müsste, weil der Apache ist, so wie er ist, ein Webserver, und ob er nun große Dateien oder kleine Dateien, ob er viele Request oder wenig Request hat, spielt dem Apache, glaube ich, keine Rolle. Es gibt natürlich solche Sachen, wie dass man sagt, okay, ein Lite zum Beispiel ist schneller als ein Apache, wenn es um statische Daten geht. Das ist richtig, weil wenn ich einen Webserver habe, der wirklich darauf ausgelegt ist, statische Daten zu servieren, dann kann der das natürlich besser als so ein, in Anführungszeichen, Application Server, wie es der Apache mittlerweile ist. Aber dadurch, dass der Apache auf der anderen Seite auch modular aufgebaut ist, kann ich auch sehr, sehr viele Module, die im Apache sind, die auch rausschmeißen und ihn auf das reduzieren, was ich tatsächlich brauche. Und dann habe ich trotzdem noch einen sehr, sehr schnellen Webserver laufen und den Schritt zum Lighty an der Stelle zu gehen, muss ich nicht unbedingt machen. Also, den muss ich vielleicht machen, wenn ich große Websites habe.
Podcasts zum Beispiel.
Erfolgreiche Podcasts.
Ich verwende ja den Lighty und bin ganz froh, dass ich das tue. Das ist für die Art Nachfrage, die ich hier erzeuge, definitiv ein Segen.
Es sind auch statische Daten, die du da hast.
Ja, jetzt haben wir ja schon die Geschichte kurz angekratzt. Was war das, 1994? Echt, so lange ist das schon her? Das ist ja wirklich, also Apache ist ja wirklich eines der allerersten Tiere überhaupt des Web, kann man sagen. Klar, ohne einen Webserver kein Web, von daher ist das ja irgendwie auch selbstverständlich. Aber nicht selbstverständlich ist, dass sich jetzt mal eine Code-Basis auch aus der Zeit in die Gegenwart rettet. Man muss sich mal anschauen, wie das auf der Browserseite gelaufen ist. Da ist ja kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen. Das ist mehrfach nun, Gott sei Dank muss man auch sagen, mehrfach komplett neu angegangen worden, mindestens zwei oder drei Mal, je nachdem, wie man das sieht. Und das ist ja auch extrem wichtig.
Ich weiß nicht beim Internet Explorer, wie da Alt-Jadi, die Code-Basis, noch ist.
Ja gut, aber ich würde auch schnell Internet Explorer als den zweiten Ansatz zählen. Und auch die, denke ich mal, sind jetzt zum dritten Ansatz gezwungen. Und so Entwicklungen wie WebKit, Chrome etc., auch Firefox und so weiter. Also da ist definitiv was passiert und da ist auch definitiv zu bestimmten Zeitpunkten eine größere Heuladung mal an Code über Bord geschmissen. Auf alle Fälle, ja. Ich habe jetzt zwar keinen Einblick, wie das beim Apache Web Server gelaufen ist, aber du sagst ja auch schon, das Ding ist sich irgendwie in gewisser Hinsicht treu und das ist dann halt auch Vor- und Nachteile in einem. So, aber jetzt steckt da ja noch ein bisschen mehr dahinter. Mit dem Namen Apache verbindet man mehr, also primär natürlich diesen Web Server, aber eben nicht nur. Der eine vielleicht mehr, der andere weniger, aber ich weiß, es gibt da auch noch mehr. Vor allem gibt es die Apache Foundation. Erik, das ist ja dein Ding. Wann ist die denn zustande gekommen und warum?
Also wir hatten schon gesagt, ja vor 15 Jahren wurde der Web Server ursprünglich von dem National Center for Supercomputing in Amerika entwickelt und wurde dann allerdings auf Halde gelegt und eine Gruppe an findigen Administratoren hat sich eben zusammengetan, die Apache Group gegründet und die Sörsen dieses Web Servers weiter gepflegt. Daraus ist dann 99 die Apache Software Foundation entstanden. Das ist nichts anderes, wie im deutschen Sinne eine gemeinnützige Organisation, ein gemeinnütziger Verein, der sich eben verschrieben hat, sich um diese Software ursprünglich zu kümmern und gleichzeitig eben auch weitere Projekte, die sich im Web-Umfeld bewegen, zu Hause zu bieten und einfache Möglichkeiten des Project-Hostings eben zu bieten. Das heißt Mailing-Listen, Bug-Tracker, Web-Server-Space, Download-Möglichkeiten und so weiter zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das Ganze kommt eben aus der Zeit, als es auch noch kein Search Forge oder GitHub wie heutzutage gab, wo Probleme ja immer darauf angewiesen waren, sich ihre eigene Infrastruktur selbst zu schaffen. Das wollte die Apache Software Foundation einfach zur Verfügung stellen.
Das heißt, es fing an mit dem Web-Server?
Genau, es fing an mit dem Web-Server.
Aber es machte da ja nicht Halt.
Genau. Über die Jahre sind dann mittlerweile über 75 verschiedene Projekte zusammengekommen. Einige aus der Java-Welt, einige aus der XML-Welt, viele Perl-Projekte, aber auch verschiedenste andere Sprachen, eben gerade der Web-Server in C, aber auch Python und ganz neue in Erlang geschriebene Projekte. Also die Apache Software Foundation ist dort nicht auf Technologien festgelegt. Solange es sich im Web-Umfeld befindet, sind wir offen für alle Projekte und alle Technologien.
Aber nicht alle im Sinne von beliebig viele, sondern es findet da schon eine Auswahl statt?
Ja, es findet natürlich eine Auswahl statt. Das Interessante an der Apache Software Foundation ist, wir bieten eben nicht nur ein anonymes Project-Hosting, sondern eben auch rechtliche Grundlagen drum herum schützen, damit zum Beispiel die Entwickler, die Communities vor rechtlichen Streitereien, was man in der heutigen Zeit immer wieder mit Patenten sieht.
Bezieht sich das jetzt im Wesentlichen auf die Lizenz, oder geht das noch darüber hinaus?
Das geht auch darüber hinaus.
Also die Apache Lizenz ist ja eine dieser BSD-artigen Lizenzen, wie du es schon gesagt hast, also eine der freiesten, in dem Sinne, dass sie...
Alles mit dem Code erlaubt.
Genau, dass man halt alles damit machen kann, sogar Geld damit verdienen und sogar den Code nicht weitergeben. Das ist ja diese alte Debatte mit, was ist denn jetzt freier? Aber gut, lassen wir das mal außen vor. Tatsache ist, die Apache Lizenz kommt eben aus diesem BSD-Lager. So, und ist das eigentlich Pflicht, dass alle Projekte im Apache Projekt diese Lizenz verwenden?
Das ist definitiv eine Pflicht. Das ist eine der Grundlagen der Apache Software Foundation.
Das heißt, ich weiß, ich lade mir Apache Software runter, dann ist das auch Apache Lizenz. Das heißt, man hat generell vor allem Firmen gegenüber eigentlich eine ganz andere Position als jetzt die Free Software Foundation?
Genau, die haben natürlich mit ihrer LGPL oder GPL ganz andere Ideen oder Visionen verfolgt wie die Apache Software Foundation. Aber eben, es kann sich jeder sicher sein, sobald man Apache runterlädt, ist das auch definitiv die Apache Lizenz und dort gibt es keine Klauseln, die irgendein Projekt extra hätte in diesem Sinne. Das wären dann wirklich andere Downloads, die woanders her als Module hinzukommen.
Und dann gibt es halt so eine Batterie von Lawyern, die sich da sozusagen um die Probleme kümmert. Welche Probleme tochen denn da auf?
Na gut, es gibt keine Batterie von Lawyern. Es gibt einen einzelnen Lawyer, Rechtsanwalt, der uns pro Bono aushilft, sprich kostenlos uns zur Verfügung steht. Und der hilft uns eben bei ganz allgemeinen Fragen. Teilweise handelt es sich allein um Trademark-Verletzungen, sprich, dass Logos in missbräuchlicher Manier auf anderen Webseiten verwendet werden, um eben einfach Werbung zu schalten und damit Geld zu verdienen.
Also wenn jetzt sozusagen andere quasi Apache-Kram nehmen, oder was?
Ja, genau, zum Beispiel.
Okay, also Selbstverteidigung. Ich habe es jetzt eher so verstanden, dass es eher um die rechtliche Beratung geht, wenn es jetzt keine Ahnung was für Probleme gibt. Deswegen frage ich ja, ob es nicht so Lizenzierungsfragen gibt.
Darum kümmern wir uns eigentlich weniger. Es geht lediglich darum, die Projekte an sich selbst vor Problemen in der Außenwelt zu schützen. Nehmen wir an, irgendein Unternehmen hält Patente und ein Apache-Projekt implementiert, Methoden, die diese Patente verletzen würden, wären dann nicht die einzelnen Entwickler dafür haftbar zu machen, sondern die Apache Software Foundation. Sie schützt somit die einzelnen Entwickler vor solchen Problemen.
Ist das schon in der Lizenz dann quasi abgebildet?
Das ist in der Lizenz abgebildet, dass der Ansprechpartner in dem Sinne nicht der Einzelentwickler ist, sondern die Apache Software Foundation als Gesamtes.
Das heißt, es gibt schon aber auch nochmal eine spezielle Apache Foundation Lizenz, weil ich kann doch auch die Apache Lizenz auf andere Projekte machen, ohne dass ich jetzt an diesem ganzen Grund bin.
Ja, aber in dem Sinne muss man ja natürlich den Namen des Urhebers ändern. Die Apache Lizenz ist ja sehr variabel gehalten. Da steht dann nicht der Name des jeweiligen.
Das heißt, für die bei der ASF gehorcheten Projekte steht da drin, die Apache Foundation ist sozusagen hier der Copyright-Holder und wenn ihr irgendwie was wollt, dann müsst ihr schon mit uns reden. Und dass man die Pro-Amira entfrieden.
Das ist natürlich ein wesentlicher Vorteil im Sinne zu einer einfachen Project-hosting-Lösung, wo man einfach seinen Code hochgibt und einzeln oder mit einer kleinen Gruppe dran arbeitet und keinerlei Möglichkeiten hat, sich vielleicht zu verteidigen.
Man ist selbst verantwortlich dann, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist ja eigentlich eine sehr dankbare Mantel, die man sozusagen den Projekten überstülpt. Aber Pro-Amira müssen die schon noch alleine.
Das auf jeden Fall. Es sind auch noch weitere Bedingungen dran geknüpft. Zum Beispiel sollten externe Projekte, die zu Apache migrieren möchten oder in die Apache Software Foundation aufgenommen werden möchten, müssen durch bestimmte Prozesse laufen. Einfach um sicherzustellen, dass der Code tatsächlich auch frei von rechtlichen Problemen ist oder abschätzbar von rechtlichen Problemen, dass alle bisherigen Rechte abgeklärt sind, dass die Apache Software Foundation sicher sein kann, damit nicht auf Rechte anderer zu verletzen. Dort haben wir einen Apache Incubator. Das ist ein eigenständiges Projekt, das sich darum kümmert, neue Projekte in die Foundation aufzunehmen. Und einerseits den Code zu überprüfen und die Herkunft des Codes, auf der anderen Seite sicherzustellen, dass die Gemeinschaft, die Community, die Regeln versteht, die Apache als grundlegende Regeln aufstellt. Da gibt es einige Dinge, an die man sich halten muss, um rechtlich auf der sicheren Seite zu sein, um auch die ganzen Dinge wie Infrastrukturen zur Verfügung stellen zu können.
Also ich versuche mir gerade vorzustellen, wie jetzt eigentlich so ein neues Projekt da tatsächlich den Weg findet. Klingelt da die ganze Tag die Tür, und die meisten werden wieder nach Hause geschickt? Oder ist das eher so ein Don't call us, we call you-Ding, das man irgendwie immer so den Open Source-Markt beobachtet und dann sagt so, hier, das wäre aber mal ein schönes Asset für uns. Sonst irgendwie, die sprechen wir mal an, ob sie nicht zu uns kommen wollen. Wie läuft das?
Das passiert eigentlich in der Regel nie. Ansprechen tun wir niemanden. Und in der Regel sind es Leute, die sich auch tatsächlich schon mit Apache Software beschäftigt haben, die wissen, welche Modelle dahinter stehen. Auf der einen Seite, wie die Community beschaffen sein sollte. Auf der anderen Seite, welche Vorteile es bietet, Apache Software zu sein. Man hat natürlich auch ein gewisses Branding und ein gewisses Image, was daraus resultiert. Da gibt es einige Projekte, die teilweise nur auf dieses Branding aus sind. Es gibt andere Projekte, die das Entwicklungsmodell und die Community sehr schätzen, die sich um Apache gebildet hat. Aufgrund dessen wollen sie teil werden. Aber direkt ansprechen tut die Apache Software Foundation eigentlich niemand.
Wenn jetzt einer ankommt und sagt, super Software, total wichtig für die Zukunft des Planeten, würde er wunderbar bei euch reinpassen. Wer fängt denn als Erstes an zu grügeln?
Dann kommt der Mensch meistens ins Unternehmen, die irgendwelche Dinge open sourcen wollen oder eigene Open Source Codebases schon haben, die sie dann aber auf eigene oder liberalere Beine stellen möchten und nicht nur in-house entwickeln oder immer an ihren Namen geknüpft haben möchten. Die kommen dann eben, schreiben meistens eine E-Mail, stellen ihr Projekt vor und fragen, ob Interesse besteht.
Wer liest das dann?
Das liest meistens auf der Incubator-Liste. Es sind ca. 50 % der Apache-Mitglieder. Das ist eine Mailing-Liste, an die man sich wenden kann.
Da ist man freiwillig drauf?
Da ist man freiwillig drauf. Deswegen sind es knapp 50 % zu jeder Zeit. Also ca. 100 Mitglieder, die sich dort auch bewegen.
Und Mitglieder sind nur Einzelpersonen oder auch Organisationen?
Mitglieder sind bei der Apache Software Foundation immer nur Einzelpersonen. Also Unternehmen haben nur die Möglichkeit, Sponsor zu werden, aber nie als Mitglied Entscheidungen zu treffen oder Ähnliches.
Wie viele Mitglieder gibt es?
Zurzeit sind es knapp 260, 275 Mitglieder.
Also so ungefähr 120 Leute gammeln auf dieser Incubator-Mainliste rum und dann kommt irgendwie einer und sagt hier, toll.
Plus aber auch noch interessierte Leute von sonst irgendwo. Also die ist öffentlich zugänglich, die Liste. Da kann auch jeder mitlesen, kann sich auch jeder einbringen auf dieser Liste.
Aber es gibt kein Stimmrecht in dem Sinne, oder?
Es gibt kein Stimmrecht für die externen Mitarbeiter. Das haben dann nur die Apache-Mitglieder in diesem Sinne. Und sobald sich dann eben eine kritische Masse, sage ich mal, gefunden hat, in dem Fall beläuft es sich auf mindestens 2-3 Apache-Mitglieder, die sagen, oh, das hört sich toll an, das würden wir gerne sponsern in diesem Sinne, lass es uns probieren.
2-3 von?
Das reicht eigentlich schon von 120. Meistens sind es dann aber bei interessanten Projekten auch 10, 15 Leute, die gleich sagen, okay, kann ich mir vorstellen, denen auszuhelfen, lass es uns probieren. Unserzeit sind gerade insgesamt 30 Projekte aktiv im Incubator und versuchen eben, ja, genau, sich in die Apache Software Foundation zu integrieren.
Und ist dann auch davon auszugehen, dass alle, die diesen Prozess einmal beschreiten, den dann auch abschließen werden?
Ja, fast ja. Also wir haben, glaube ich, einen Conversion Rate, wenn man das so sagen kann, von 90 oder 80 Prozent. Die meisten Dinge sind...
Na gut, 80 Prozent heißt, jeder Fünfte schafft es nicht oder er kehrt selber wieder um oder man findet irgendwas Schlimmes.
Na ja, 80 Prozent der Projekte kommen durch und werden dann tatsächlich auch Apache-Projekte.
Ja gut, deswegen, also 20 Prozent schaffen es nicht, auf die wollte ich hin, also warum dann nicht?
Meistens die fehlende Möglichkeit, eine Community auf die Beine zu stellen. Grundlage jedes Apache-Projekts ist eine eigenständige Community, die sich natürlich um den Code kümmert. Und da reicht es nicht nur ein oder zwei Leute zu haben, oder dann auch von, zum Beispiel, wenn eine externe Firma eben Code open sourcen möchte und ihn zu Apache bringen möchte, reicht es nicht, wenn dann acht Entwickler dieser Firma nur an diesem Projekt arbeiten. Wir möchten schon eine diverse...
Wie kann man das denn nachweisen?
Ja, das wird eben in diesem Incubator über eine gewisse Zeitdauer versucht, rauszufinden, ob das möglich ist, ob auch genügend Interesse von Entwicklern besteht, dort mitzuarbeiten.
Was für einen Zeitraum reden wir so? Wie lange läuft so ein Prozess ungefähr?
Die schnellsten Projekte, die wir, glaube ich, hatten, waren innerhalb von einigen Wochen, vier bis sechs, acht Wochen, durch den Incubator gelaufen. Es gibt aber auch Projekte, die mittlerweile seit ein, zwei Jahren dort drinstecken und sich eigentlich wenig fortbewegen. In diesem Sinne kündigen wir dann auch niemanden und werfen diese Projekte raus. Nach einer gewissen Zeit erledigt sich das entweder von selber oder sie sind halt erfolgreich und bilden oder bringen eine Community, stellen eine Community auf die Beine, die dann das Projekt, naja, betreibt.
Das heißt, entweder schaffen sie es dann irgendwann oder sie geben selber auf oder sie gammeln auf Ewigkeiten in Inkubator rum und werden da so vor sich hin aufgewärmt.
Ja, nach einer gewissen Zeit lang, wenn man es sieht, da ist keine Aktivität mehr, kommen sie natürlich auch in die Kämmer.
Aber wie erkennt man denn das? Ich meine, klar, es mag natürlich Projekte geben, da stürzt sich dann irgendwie die ganze Welt drauf.
Genau.
Die Leute kriegen nicht genug davon, dann ist das irgendwie klar. Aber irgendwo muss es ja auch so einen messbaren Threshold geben. Woran sagt man, okay, alles klar, das ist jetzt so die kritische Masse, das nennen wir jetzt eine Community.
Also direkte Matrix, die wir da anlegen, haben wir eigentlich auch nicht. Das ist allein gefühlt. Deswegen sind eben auch der Großteil der Mitglieder auch dort engagiert, weil sie jahrelange Erfahrungen mit Projekten und mit Open Source und Communities an sich haben. Und das ist dann wirklich ja ein gefühltes Ding. Also man versucht eben rauszufinden.
Was ist deine Relation zu der Größe des Projektes?
Genau, ja.
Umso größer, dass mehr Leute sich drum kümmern müssten.
Der Ursprung spielt eine Rolle, zum Beispiel jetzt im Fall von Subversion. Subversion hatte schon eine aktive Entwickler-Community. Sprich, da ist es natürlich viel, viel einfacher, wie wenn ich jetzt ein In-House-Projekt von einem großen Unternehmen nehme und das das erste Mal ans Tageslicht bringe. Da muss ich mir natürlich erstmal Interessenten finden, Entwickler zusammensuchen, vielleicht ein bisschen Werbung auch für das Projekt machen. Und da haben wir dann auch so Geschichten wie Apache-Konferenzen, wo natürlich auch neue Projekte vorgestellt werden und wo dann auch externe Leute oder auch andere Unternehmen aufmerksam auf neue Projekte werden und sich somit dann auch wieder Synergien zwischen Projekten ergeben.
Ist das eigentlich das Apache-Friends-Projekt, steht das jetzt so komplett für sich alleine oder gibt es da auch irgendeine Interaktion jetzt mit der Foundation?
Da steht er alleine da. Wir beide kennen uns jetzt, aber auch privat, aber sonst haben wir eigentlich mit der Apache Software Foundation wenig zu tun. Besonders auch, weil wir uns ja wirklich genau um den Apache-Webserver nur kümmern. Das heißt, gar nicht mit den anderen Produkten großartig was zu tun haben oder mit anderen Projekten zu tun haben, die da in der Apache Group vertreten sind. Deswegen sind unsere Ziele auch schon anders. Bei der Apache Group geht es darum, Produkte zu hosten oder Projekte zu hosten. Und wir kümmern uns ganz allein nur um den Apache-Webserver und auch da in dem Fall auch nur um eine ganz bestimmte Zielgruppe, nämlich den Einstieg in diese Technologie.
Jetzt sind ja die Projekte beim Apache Foundation eigentlich keine klassischen Einsteiger-Tools, nicht wahr? Es ist ja schon ein großer Schwerpunkt, würde ich sagen, liegt auf Development.
Absolut, ja. Unsere Zielgruppe sind eigentlich Entwickler oder Core-Infrastrukturen, also knackigere Dinge wie jetzt nur das Entwickeln von Webseiten oder solchen Geschichten.
Und gibt es da, also ich meine, gut, wenn ich mir diesen Incubator-Prozess anschaue, dann kommt halt immer irgendjemand dazu und dann denkt man sich, passt das sozusagen zu uns kulturell? Passt das zu uns, ich denke mal auch, also gibt es dann sozusagen, also ist Teil dieses Prozesses auch eine Bewertung, passt das zum Portfolio? Ist das sozusagen eine Ergänzung? Was wäre, wenn ein Produkt mit einem anderen da irgendwie in den selben Bereich kämpft?
Das gibt es eigentlich gar nicht, ja. Wir geben keinerlei Regeln vor, ob sich jetzt konkurrierende Produkte dort befinden können oder nicht. Wir haben auch keinerlei Strategien, welche Produkte oder Projekte jetzt interessant wären für die Apache Software Foundation. Da sind wir eigentlich relativ offen und lassen alles zu.
Das heißt, es gibt jetzt auch nicht so wie ein, es gibt jetzt nicht so einen Masterplan, wir wollen die Infrastruktur für das Web 3.0 bauen und da beugen wir noch das und das, sondern es kommt halt einfach so zusammen, wie es zusammenkommt. Und wichtig ist, dass diese Projekte in sich, die in Anforderungen genügen, die Mitglieder eigenständig sind, selber irgendwie schon so ein Mindestmaß haben, damit sie quasi förderungswürdig sind. Das heißt, da kommen auch eher die Projekte hin, die schon so eine gewisse, wie soll man sagen, so eine gewisse Maturität erreicht haben, die einfach schon so ein Minimum bewiesen haben, die nicht komplett frisch sind. Aber das heißt ja auch nicht, dass alle Projekte jetzt erfolgreich sind, die bei der Apache Foundation... Was sind denn so die Tops und die Flops, wollte ich jetzt schon fast sagen, aber anders aufgebunden. Du hast ja schon gesagt, es gab Schwerpunkte. Als ich das erste Mal die Foundation so richtig ein bisschen auf dem Radar hatte, da hatte ich so den Eindruck, dass vor allem diese Java-XML-Welt sehr stark vertreten war. Genau, deswegen fragte ich auch gerade noch mal mit der Strategie, das kam mir schon fast strategisch vor. Ja, was weiß ich, mit so Sachen wie Cuckooen, dieser XML-Webpublishing-Geschichte, Tomcat und so weiter. Also es macht so den Eindruck, als ob sich da quasi so eine Gesamtinfrastruktur auch versucht zu finden, um dann als Ganzes auch zu wirken.
Ja, das kann den Eindruck machen, war aber eigentlich nie das Ziel der ganzen Geschichte. Das ist eigentlich historisch gesehen ganz interessant. Es waren ja die Leute, heutzutage sind es 300 Mitglieder, damals waren es eben vielleicht 50 Mitglieder. Und die haben eben die Richtung bestimmt. Also die Interessen lagen damals bei vielen eben auf Java. Die kamen auch viele eben von Sun damals. Und damit hat sich ja die Richtung eingeschlagen. Aber es wurde nie explizit bestimmt oder entschieden, wir sollten in die Richtung gehen. Wenn man heute auch fragt, was den einzelnen oder das einzelne Mitglied interessiert, bekommt man von den 300 Mitgliedern auch 300 unterschiedliche, komplett unterschiedliche Antworten. Also es gab auch innerhalb der Apache Software Foundation immer mal wieder Konflikte, gerade weil es die Java, die Java-Ecke zu groß wurde und man nur seinen Augenmerk teilweise darauf legen konnte. Aber das war einer der Gründe, warum wir dann auch das ursprüngliche Jakarta-Projekt aufgelöst haben und eigenständige Projekte aus diesen ganzen Subprojekten, damaligen Subprojekten entwickelt haben.
Also Jakarta war so quasi...
Das war so die Sammlung aller Java-Projekte bei Apache.
Also da gab es schon so ein bisschen so ein Metaprogramm eigentlich.
Ja, da hat sich in der Foundation fast eine zweite Foundation entwickelt, die nur in diese Richtung dann eigentlich ging.
Aber das wollte man dann nicht?
Wollte man nicht, nee nee.
Da waren sie alle einig oder war das dann irgendwie...
Gut, es gab Diskussionen bei vielen Leuten. Da gab es die eine Richtung, die andere Richtung. Aber am Ende des Tages hat man sich auch zusammengefunden und eben das Beste daraus gemacht. Und man sieht, das ist erfolgreich bis heute. Die meisten Projekte werden überall in der Java-Welt immer noch eingesetzt oder auch aktivst weiterentwickelt. Also die Java-Welt ohne Apache wäre wahrscheinlich das, was sie heute wäre.
Was sind denn so die erfolgreichsten und wichtigsten Projekte aus deiner Position heraus?
Wir hatten den Web-Server, den wahrscheinlich jeder kennt, schon allein wegen des Namens Apache Web-Server. Dann gäbe es ja im Java-Umfeld den Tomcat als Application-Server zu nennen, Hadoop als neueste Technologie.
Vielleicht noch ein Satz mehr zu diesem Tomcat. Der Application-Server ist quasi ein Modul, das eher der Dispatcher, der Verteiler ist, um Program-Environments in den Web-Server einzubinden.
Genau, in dem Falle ist er natürlich auch ein eigener Web-Server und wird so häufig als Web-Server und Application-Server betrieben. In anderen Fällen natürlich als nur Application-Server, wo dann andere Web-Server davor stehen. Das ist der Tomcat.
Spielt das bei euch auch eine Rolle, bei XAMPP, solche Sachen?
Ja, es spielt eine Rolle, weil eben auch bei XAMPP selbst direkt jetzt kein Java dabei ist. Sondern wir fokussieren uns hauptsächlich auf PHP. Aber es gibt eben auch viele Entwickler, die in Java entwickeln wollen. Und dann brauchen sie so einen Application-Server, wie zum Beispiel Tomcat. Und dann gibt es bei uns laufenden auch solche Fragen an, wie kann ich jetzt den Apache Web-Server mit dem Tomcat Application-Server verbinden? Und da gibt es dann auch verschiedene Möglichkeiten, mit denen ich das machen kann. Und da gibt es dann wieder Berührungspunkte tatsächlich.
Also Tomcat, der ist ja eigentlich sehr verbreitet, kann man sagen. Das ist schon eher ein erfolgreiches Ding, ne?
Absolut, ja.
Andere Beispiele?
Dann gibt es natürlich noch ganz frische Projekte, wie auch das Hadoop erst seit einigen Jahren, jetzt im Vergleich zu Tomcat, was fast seit Gründung mit der Apache fast zusammenfließt, oder zumindest der Software Foundation. Dann noch aktuellere Projekte, wie CouchDB, was auch immer.
Sagen wir mal kurz etwas zu dem Hadoop.
Das kommt zu, ein Beispiel, ursprünglich aus Yahoo, ging damals auch durch den Incubator und wurde dann volles Projekt der Apache Software Foundation.
Das ist im Prinzip so das Google für Arme, oder?
Ja, für Arme. Was heißt für Arme? Heutzutage arbeitet sogar komplette Yahoo damit. Also mag man von Arme sprechen.
Also es ist ein Storage-System, was in diese klassische NoSQL-Geschichte mit reinfällt?
Eigentlich nicht in die NoSQL-Geschichte, eigentlich nur in die Suchgeschichte, in das verteilte Suchen über riesige Datenmengen hinweg. Die NoSQL-Geschichte wäre dann eher ein Dokumenten-Storage-System, wie das, was CouchDB als ganz frisches Projekt zur Verfügung stellen würde. Also noch mal ein kleiner Unterschied dazwischen.
CouchDB war ja hier auch schon zu Gast, Chaosradio Express 125. Da haben wir das schon mal ausführlicher beleuchtet. Der Zusammenhang mit der Apache Foundation war auch ein bisschen für mich der Anlass, das Thema aufzusuchen. Das sind ja auch alles schon auch so Projekte, die für meinen Geschmack auch versuchen, den Status quo, wie man so programmiert und wie man so seine Systeme zusammenbaut, auch so ein bisschen nach vorne zu treiben. Ich baue mir etwas, was so funktioniert wie eine Google-Suchmaschine, oder RU in dem Zusammenhang, nicht wahr? Oder dann eben auch CouchDB mit irgendwie, wir machen das jetzt alles mal ohne SQL. Das sind ja schon relativ, ja, teils ketzerisch, ansässig übertreibend. Aber zumindest ist es der Versuch, progressiv einfach neue Wege zu finden. Aber nenn ruhig noch mal ein paar.
Dann hätten wir als prominentes Projekt natürlich noch Spam Assassin, den allseits bekannten Anti-Spam-Lösung. Dann auch noch Subversion relativ neu, was es ja auch jetzt seit einigen Jahren gibt und mittlerweile auch von einigen schon wieder als überholt gilt.
Versionskontrolle, ja. Haben wir uns hier auch vor kurzem auf das Lichtrohr beschäftigt, also beziehungsweise haben wir uns nicht mehr mit Subversion beschäftigt, sondern eben mit den potenziellen Nachfolgern. Mercurial und Git vor allem. Ist einer von den beiden bei euch gelandet? Ja, aber trotzdem Subversion ist auch hier zu sehen.
Das wird noch lange verwendet werden.
Gar keine Frage.
Was gäbe es noch? Bei über 75 Projekten verliert man ja leicht den Überblick. Also es gibt noch einen ganzen Haufen Dinge.
Ich finde ja diese XML-Welt immer ganz interessant, weil das auch so gerade experimentell war. Aber ich habe immer den Eindruck, die kamen so recht nicht vom Fleck. Ich hatte ja schon dieses Kuckun erwähnt.
Ich glaube, das ist ein konzeptionelles Problem, dass XML für manche Dinge eben geeignet ist, dann aber für viele andere Dinge verwendet wurde, für die es einfach keinen Sinn macht, das zu verwenden. Was natürlich trotzdem damals sehr wichtig war, als Referenzimplementation von überhaupt XML-Parsern und XML-Interpretern, die Projekte Xalan und Xarkus bei Apache, die ja bis heute Standard auch in der XML-Verarbeitung im Bereich Java sind. Das sind natürlich wieder so grundlegende Technologien, die dann eher Apache seinen Augenmerk legt, wie userbezogene oder oberflächelbasierte Programme, also...
Ja. Das sind auch diese Teil von diesen... Das sind jetzt die Java, ne? Ah, nee, das ist nicht nur in Java, das sind...
Gibt es auch eben C-Implementationen.
Also Xalan ist der XSLT-Prozessor, oder?
Genau, Xalan, ja. Prozessor ist der XML-Parser.
Ach ja, XSLT. Ich hab's nie verwendet, das Xalan, aber... Ich weiß, das verwenden Leute.
Na ja, vielleicht hast du's schon verwendet, du wusstest es aber gar nicht, weil so viele Software eben damit funktioniert.
Ach so, ja, das kann natürlich sein, indirekt so.
Und ja, gibt's eben noch einen ganzen Haufen anderer Projekte. Da steh ich jetzt fast auf dem Schlaufe.
ModPearl ist auch noch bei euch.
ModPearl, ja, natürlich ein Modul für Apache.
ModPearl, also nicht Pearl selbst, sondern...
Nicht Pearl selbst, sondern ModPearl. Und vorher sind wir schon drauf gekommen, dass ursprünglich sogar PHP mal ein Apache-Projekt war. Das hat sich dann aber im Jahr 2001, 2002 als Schwesterprojekt ausgeklinkt und wollte komplett eigenständig sein, hat es dann auch gemacht und war auch bis heute erfolgreich.
Ja, PHP hat ja wahrscheinlich dann auch für sich schon genug Größe erreicht, um sich seine Strukturen da selber zu schaffen. Gar keine Frage. Schau hier gerade mal so durch die Liste. Also manches kennt man, manches kennt man aber auch wirklich überhaupt nicht. Das ist... Was war denn noch mal Strats?
Es sind auch nicht alle Projekte wirklich erfolgreich in diesem Sinne. Manche Projekte führen auch eine Nischen-Dasein oder haben auch nur kleine erfolgreiche Nischen.
Aber Jakarta ist jetzt hier schon noch... Also es gibt es noch, ne?
Es gibt es noch, ist allerdings kein Projekt, wie es damals war, was aus diesen ganzen Java-Unterprojekten bestanden hat. Es ist glaube ich bisher nur noch archiv aktiv gerade.
Hier steht auch irgendwie extrakarta. Also AND hier, dieses Java-Bild-Tool.
Genau, das ist noch sehr prominent, ja.
Das kommen auch noch dazu. Das heißt, grundsätzlich ist die Apache Foundation aber auch sozusagen offen für Erweiterungen. Also falls jetzt sozusagen jemand ein Projekt hat, was Community-Appeal hat und sonst irgendwie so das Interesse findet. Ich frage mich halt so ein bisschen, wie man das so einschätzen muss, was eigentlich so das Interesse dieser Community ist. Ich meine, ist das jetzt wirklich immer nur so ein langweiliger Prozess? Und ja, ihr könnt jetzt so die Community zusammen bekommen oder nicht. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da auch schon, ich meine, dass die Leute sich da engagieren, wenn man sich engagiert, wenn man ja auch mal so ein bisschen den Kick haben, dass sie schon auch so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach dem Besonderen sind.
Absolut, ja. Die Leute, die wollen natürlich einerseits das Branding, was ich schon erwähnt hatte, ist natürlich ein schönes Ding. Als Apache-Projekt im Internet zu stehen, ist natürlich wertvoller als XY-Projekt. Auf der anderen Seite kennen viele eben auch die gedanklichen Modelle, die hinter dem entwickeln bei der Apache Software Foundation stehen. Eine der Prämissen ist ja zum Beispiel Community Overcode. Das heißt, der Code ist nicht das Wichtigste bei Apache, sondern die Leute sind tatsächlich das Wichtigste. Und das sieht man auch an solchen Abstimmungsprozessen oder an anderen Dingen, wie die Projekte eben finden, in welche Richtung sie gehen. Es gibt keine Chefs, keine Führer in diesem Sinne, die das Projekt bestimmen. Es gibt nur Mitglieder, die durch ihre Arbeit am Projekt bestimmen, welche Richtung das Projekt dann auch einnimmt. Das heißt, es ist ein sehr, sehr flüssiger Prozess, wie die Leute miteinander zusammenarbeiten, um dann eben gemeinsam auf ein Ziel zu kommen, nämlich erstklassige Software zu entwickeln.
Aber wie sich jetzt die Software-Projekte intern organisieren, darüber gibt es eigentlich keine Aussage.
Es gibt lediglich ein paar Regeln, wie Abstimmungen abzulaufen haben. Zum Beispiel durch die berühmten plus eins, minus eins hat dann jedes Mitglied eines Projekts die Möglichkeit, seine Zustimmung oder Abneigung auszudrücken.
Was meinst du jetzt so, auf Mailing-Listen?
Auf Mailing-Listen zum Beispiel wird plus eins immer als Abkürzung für Zustimmung gesehen. Das kommt ursprünglich aus der Apache-Welt und wurde da eben als einfaches Mittel zur Wahl betrachtet, auf einer Mailing-Liste einfach einen Konsensus zu finden.
Echt Wahlen auf Mailing-Listen, die funktionieren?
Bei jedem Release der Apache Software Foundation geht so eine Wahl voraus. Von dem her, es funktioniert seit Jahren ohne Probleme.
Ist das denn dann auch schon so eine Versammlung der Graubärte?
Manchmal vielleicht auch. Wir haben natürlich Leute, die seit extrem langen Jahren in der Software-Entwicklungswelt unterwegs sind und die schon frühzeitig zur Apache gefunden haben und wie wir festgestellt haben, seit 15 Jahren, seit den Anfängen des Web, sprich, das ist dann doch schon die erste Generation der Web-Citizens anstatt eben die eher jungen Leute.
Also du hast noch keinen grauen Bart.
Ich noch nicht, aber die Haare werden langsam irgendwo.
Okay, lass mir das Thema.
Wenn man sich lang genug damit beschäftigt, dann werden sie einfach zwangsläufig grau. Was mich noch interessiert, ist dieses Verhältnis zu Firmen. Wir haben ja schon angedeutet, die Apache-Lizenz ist eine recht business-kompatible Lizenz, da sie ja im Prinzip sagt, kannst du nehmen, kannst du machen, was du willst. Das tun ja manche dann auch. Das ist ein bestes Beispiel. Microsoft hat sich ja dann auch mal das TCP-IP einverleibt. Man konnte aber zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht feststellen, dass sie dann groß in dieser BSD-Welt da kontributiert hätten. Das sehen ja dann manche dann immer schon gleich so als den Sündenfall an. Andere sagen, who cares? Dann haben sie halt auch entsprechend Probleme, das dann wieder selbst zu maintainen, wenn sie nicht mit dem Mainstream mitlaufen. Aber was ich ganz interessant finde, ist so, wie ist denn dann sozusagen grundsätzlich das Verhältnis zu der Firmenlandschaft? Du hast ja auch schon von Branding gesprochen. Das Ganze hat schon so einen gewissen Marken-Appeal. Da werden wir dann auch irgendwas erreichen. Wie findet da ein Austausch statt? Und wie sieht der aus?
Hauptsächlich eben auf Konferenzen, dass man dort eben mit verschiedenen Unternehmen in Gespräche kommt. Dass viele Unternehmen anfangen, sich über die Apache Software Foundation kundig zu machen. Da Open Source immer mehr ein Thema wird, eigene Software zu Open Sourceen, um eben die Masse der Entwickler im Web auch nutzen zu können. Auf der anderen Seite eben seine Projekte oder Produkte auch bekannt zu machen. Allerdings, die Apache Software Foundation geht niemals offiziell oder offensichtlich auf Unternehmen zu, wenn dann kommen meistens eben Unternehmen und wollen entweder Sponsor werden oder wie gesagt ihre Projekte in einen Incubator reingeben, um da natürlich ein bisschen von diesem Apache-Brand einfach zu profitieren. Auf der anderen Seite eben auch die Community stabil zu machen und stabil zu halten.
Wie groß ist denn der Wasserkopf?
Eigentlich, ich würde behaupten, superschlank. Wir haben keinerlei festangestellten Systemadministrator und einen Secretarial Assistant, sprich der hilft dem Tagesgeschäft bei verschiedenen Paperwork-Geschichten. Ansonsten regeln das ganze Tagesgeschäft neuen Vorstände, also im Vergleich zu einem deutschen Verein werden das Vorstände. Und die Projekte dann an sich alleine. Sprich in dem Sinne, es gibt keinen Wasserkopf, es gibt teilweise eben bürokratische Hürden. Zum Beispiel wird nur Schreibrechte auf die Code Repositories gegeben, nachdem ein sogenanntes Committer License Agreement unterzeichnet wurde. Einfach um sicherzustellen, dass man weiß, von wem kommt ein bestimmter Teil des Codes. Nichts anderes ist damit verbunden. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen bürokratischer Overhead, aber ansonsten gibt es keinen Wasserkopf in der Foundation.
Also es gibt auch keine festen Büros?
Es gibt keine festen Büros. Wir haben eben eine Stelle in den Staaten. Dort sind wir registriert als gemeinnütziger Verein. Dort ist auch ein offizielles Büro, aber keine festangestellten Mitarbeiter, die da jeden Morgen zur Arbeit auftauchen würden oder Ähnliches. Das findet alles auf Mailinglisten statt und ist auch alles transparent und einsehbar für den Rest der Welt.
Und so deine Erfahrung konkret mit Deutschland, ist das vergleichbar? Also hier die Wahrnehmung von Apache, gerade so was so das Miteinander mit Firmen betrifft, ist das Interesse vergleichbar?
Deutschland ist immer, oder auch wir in Europa, sind immer ein bisschen den Staaten hinterher, was die neuesten Technologien und so weiter anbelangt. Von dem her kam dieses ganze Open-Source-Thema natürlich auch ein bisschen später hier an. Aber gerade die großen internationalen Unternehmen wie IBM, Sun und so weiter haben das ja auch relativ schnell begriffen, dass es ein Thema sein wird in der nächsten Zeit. Und ja, ich denke wir Deutsche sind da super aufgestellt und haben ja auch eine riesige Community an deutschen Entwicklern, sei es jetzt im Linux-Bereich, in anderen Open-Source-Projekten und auch bei Apache.
Was ist jetzt so, Sun, IBM, das ist immer so das erste Beispiel. Da merkt man, die haben ja vor einiger Zeit ihre Firmenkultur auch gänzlich gewandelt. Beide setzen ganz konkret auf offene Technologien. Bei Sun kann man darüber diskutieren. Teilweise hatten sie Open-Source, teilweise nicht. Dann haben sie eine eigene Lizenz. Das war auch ein bisschen Eierei. Jetzt muss man eben mal schauen, wie es mit Sun weitergeht, wo es Oracle ist. Bei IBM gab es irgendwann ganz klar diese Öffnung mit, ja, das OS ist jetzt hier für unseren Markt nicht mehr im einigen Sinne wichtig, sondern wir nehmen jetzt einfach Linux und nutzen da sozusagen auch diese Offenheit, weil unser Business ist irgendwie Enterprise und Consulting und Beratung und Systeme zusammenschrauben. Das können wir irgendwie auch damit machen. Das waren ja ganz interessante Sachen. Aber was ist mit so Firmen wie, was weiß ich, Microsoft oder Apple? Ich meine, bei Apple weiß man ja, dass sie auch einen guten Teil apache Software zum Einsatz bringen, ja auch mit ausliefern. Wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, der Apache Server ist ja bei Mac mit dabei. Gibt es denn da auch ein Miteinander?
Also wir haben tatsächlich Mitglieder in der Apache Software Foundation, die auch bei Apple arbeiten, allerdings nicht von Apple dafür bezahlt werden, in Apache mitzuarbeiten oder Ähnliches. Das sind einfach auch, wie Kai schon sagte, gemeinnützige oder ehrenamtliche Tätigkeiten, wie immer bei Apache. Also dort wird keiner bezahlt, um dort mitzuarbeiten. Und manchmal kommen gerade von Apple auch Patches zurück, das hält sich aber sehr sehr in Grenzen. Microsoft in den letzten paar Monaten, beziehungsweise im letzten Jahr, kommt immer progressiver auf die Open Source Communities zu und auch auf Apache, mittlerweile sind sie auch Gold-Sponsor oder so was Ähnliches. Ja und versuchen eben auch einen Fuß langsam noch in den Markt zu fassen, was sie als Markt betrachten.
Aber die bei irgendwelchen Projekten mit, weißt du das?
Aktiv mitarbeiten tun sie bei uns nirgends, weil sie es soweit ich weiß immer noch intern die Philosophie haben, dass eben keiner an Open Source Projekten mitarbeiten darf offiziell. Sie unterstützen uns allerdings mit einerseits einem Sponsorship, andererseits mit Entwicklungstools. Der Microsoft Developer Network ist zum Beispiel für alle Apache-Mitglieder zugänglich, damit wir auch Möglichkeiten haben, mit den Microsoft Entwicklungstools zu arbeiten, ohne da jetzt Geld ausgeben zu müssen. Aber damit beschränkt sich das Ganze dann schon.
Was mit Google?
Google ist auch relativ Open Source interessiert natürlich. Es kamen auch schon einige Projekte oder kleinere Dinge von Google oder auch als Sponsor natürlich zu erwähnen. Und Google ist natürlich ein Freund der Apache-Lizenz. Also die meisten der Google-Projekte sind natürlich auch unter der Apache-Lizenz veröffentlicht, weil sie die Vorteile ähnlich wie Apache auch sehen.
Das hat ja Apple auch gemacht. Apple hat ja auch einige Sachen, vor allem auch WebKit. In einem zweiten Schritt, genau. WebKit ist auch Apache-Lizenz? Soweit ich weiß, Apache muss ich gar nicht. Was finden wir denn gerade konkret ein? Dieser Streaming-Server. Also sie haben auf jeden Fall ein paar Sachen rausgebracht. Das waren diese BSD-Tools hier, so LaunchD und solche.
Ja, diese Darwin-Geschichten.
Genau, wo sie am Anfang auch mit ihrer Apple-Lizenz losmarschiert sind und dann später aber dann auch tatsächlich auf die Apache-Lizenz umgeschwenkt sind. Ich schätze mal, das hat auch was damit zu tun. Mit dieser Brand-Recognition, dass man sagt, wir setzen auf die Apache, wäre die Frage.
Das wäre die Frage, ob du auch teilweise die Lizenz vielleicht aus branding-Gründen genommen hast. Das glaube ich jetzt eher weniger, aber vielleicht.
Auch schon bei dieser Sun-Lizenz, die ja alle irgendwie diese Open-Source-Lizenz-Anforderungen und so weiter irgendwie erfüllen. Also wenn man da die Checkliste durchgeht und sagt, naja, an sich ist das halt auch eine. Ich glaube, die Leute fragen sich schon auch so ein bisschen so, naja, wenn das jetzt das Gleiche ist, warum steht da Apple drin?
Na ja, es ist eben auch die Frage, wie viele Lizenzen brauchen wir wirklich? Wie viele gedankliche Modelle kann man in solchen Lizenzen abbilden, dass es Sinn macht?
Ja, wenn es einen eigenen Namen hat, dann muss es auch anders sein. Und wenn es anders ist, muss ich wieder eine neue Lizenz lernen. Und ich denke, dass man auch schon...
Was ist anders?
Dass man schon so allein so mit dieser GPL- und BSD-Split irgendwie schon eigentlich mental genug zu tun hat. Und sich dann halt nicht nochmal um solche anderen Varianten drum kümmern kann. Also da auch ein interessanter Weg, wie man sozusagen an dieses Apache-Universum andocken kann, ohne jetzt unmittelbar mit ihm was zu tun zu haben.
Um da noch historisch anzuknüpfen, zum Beispiel die erste Apache-License, die war ja sehr, sehr spezifisch auf die Apache Software Foundation zugeschnitten. Da wir aber eben gemerkt haben, dass die Lizenz sehr vielen Leuten eben zusagt, sie es ja auch gerne selber verwenden möchten, wurde die zweite Version der Apache-Lizenz dann auch spezifisch daraufhin entwickelt, dass sie eben von allen anderen Projekten auch einsetzbar ist, also externen Projekten oder Unternehmen, ohne sich großartige Gedanken zu machen.
Ja, wo geht jetzt die Reise hin?
Das bestimmen die 300 Mitglieder mit ihren 300 einzelnen Meinungen.
Was ist so dein Eindruck? Also, ich meine, gibt es da irgendwie so einen Trend, was für Projekte da jetzt so andocken ist? Der Kahn fährt jetzt einfach weiter in die gleiche Richtung.
Der Kahn fährt und wir sind immer auf der Suche oder immer gerne bereit, neue Projekte aufzunehmen und wir würden uns auch zum Beispiel über mobile oder bei Libraries aus dem mobilen Bereich freuen, zum Beispiel für Android oder für andere Produkte. Also, da sind in der Sache keine Grenzen gesetzt. Wie gesagt, der Apache ist da sehr, sehr offen.
Aber so richtige Applikationen, also Standalone-Applikationen, gibt es bei euch gar nicht?
Die gibt es eigentlich gar nicht, aber das hat auch nur historische Gründe, da eigentlich auch niemand damit ankam. Also, von dem her hat sich schon so ein bisschen der Pfad von alleine dann gesetzt auf Dauer.
Also du meinst, dass es jetzt im Wesentlichen sich alles um Enabling Technologies handelt und nicht so sehr um einfach einen Web-Shop oder so was? Aber dem steht eigentlich nichts?
Steht eigentlich nichts im Wege. Nur scheinbar sind die Interessenten oder die Entwickler solcher Tools anderen Organisationen mehr zugeneigt. Also es gibt ja noch einen ganzen Haufen anderer Organisationen, die auch nach dem Vorbild von Apache dann entstanden sind. Wie zum Beispiel die Eclipse Foundation, die sich jetzt um eine Java-basiertes IDE- Entwicklungsumgebung kümmert. Die ist natürlich nach dem Vorbild von Apache auch ein bisschen entstanden und haben sich danach auch eben ja gebildet. Von dem her gibt es da auch keinen...
Gibt es noch andere Beispiele von solchen Gruppen, die sich so in demselben mentalen...
Na ja Mozilla ist ähnlich. Es sind auch teilweise eine Überlappung der Leute, die sich in Apache oder Mozilla oder auch in anderen großen Projekten eben aufhalten. Wir haben teilweise Mitglieder, die in vielen Projekten... Da werden die Grauberte dann geschehen.
Haben wir noch etwas Wichtiges vergessen? Du hast Konferenzen erwähnt. Was gibt es da? Wo trifft man sich? Was sind so die Bierparties, die man versuchen kann, wenn es um Apache geht?
Gerade von der Apache Software Foundation selbstständig aus haben wir meistens zwei oder eine Konferenz pro Jahr. Mindestens einmal in den Staaten und dann meistens noch Europa oder Asien. Das ist immer so eine fragliche Geschichte, wann was zustande kommt. Wobei wir jetzt langsam anfangen, auch kleinere User-Events zu sponsoren und auszuhelfen. Also, dass wir da nicht darauf angewiesen sind, dass die sich komplett alleine bilden und organisieren müssen. Die bekommen dann auch finanzielle Unterstützung oder Ähnliches.
Ist das denn so die Natur von User Groups?
Ja, genau.
Wie heißen denn diese Konferenzen?
Die Konferenzen heißen ApacheCon. Also relativ einfach.
Und worum geht es da?
Da geht es um eigentlich alle Projekte, die es bei Apache gibt. Einerseits eben die administrativen Dinge von Apache und auch so ein Blick hinter die Vorhänge des Ganzen. Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich um die ganzen eigenen Projekte und dann die technischen Fragen drum herum. Das sind hauptsächlich Entwicklerkonferenzen.
Das heißt, da treffen sich im Prinzip diese ganzen Projekte, stellen ihre Arbeit vor, wohin sie wollen, was sie gemacht haben?
Zum Beispiel, genau. Und machen dann auch spezielle Tracks und Präsentationen über die Arbeit mit ihren Projekten. Also wie konfiguriere ich Apache als einfachstes Beispiel bis hin zu wie setze ich eben CouchDB als meine NoSQL-Datenbank ein?
Also in gewisser Hinsicht ist es dann auch für die Entwickler noch mal so ein zusätzliches Forum in so einer relativ erfahrenen Community, kann man ja sagen. Da sind sie wieder die Grauberte, wo man dann sozusagen andocken kann. Ich vermute mal, das ist dann eher schon noch so ein ganz starkes Argument dafür, auch jetzt sagen wir mal überhaupt in so einer Community anzudocken. Also egal, ob es jetzt Apache oder Mozilla oder was auch immer ist. Es passt sozusagen zu anderen Technologien, die da ohnehin schon sind. Und auch wenn das unmittelbar jetzt für die Entwicklung meines Projekts so konkret nicht notwendig ist, gibt es dann halt einfach da eine Community von Leuten, die denkt einfach auf dem gleichen Level, sage ich mal. Also hat einfach ein genauso weitgehendes Verständnis vom Web und so weiter. Und man redet da nicht sozusagen um den heißen Brei rum.
Genau, ja. Also man kann eben zum Punkt kommen, und da treffen sich eben auch gleich Gefimte, die dann ja an solchen Dingen arbeiten oder sich austauschen möchten, spezielle Synergien suchen oder auch teilweise die eben von Unternehmen dafür bezahlt werden, an Open Source-Projekten mitzuarbeiten, weil es zum Beispiel in ihrem eigenen Produkt ein wichtiger Teil ist.
Ist es in Apache Conan also keine Anwenderkonferenz in dem Sinne?
Na ja, Anwender im Sinne für unsere Software, was gleichzeitig natürlich wieder Entwickler sind. Also unsere Zielgruppe, unsere Anwender sind Entwickler, und keine End-User in diesem Sinne. Deswegen sind ja auch die meisten Projekte so einen Library-Charakter. Also eher dieser Bibliotheks- oder Sinn- oder...
Und damit wäre der Anwender auch gleichzeitig ein Entwickler.
Müsstest du dann nicht auch mal aufschlagen mit deinem Apache-Friends irgendwie aus dem Apache-Code?
Das passt eben nicht, weil wir eher weniger... Wir sind ja eher der End-Anwender.
Es geht ja mehr so um diesen...
Kai ist eigentlich unsere Zielgruppe. Wir geben ja nur Source-Code in diesem Sinne raus, und er verpackt das Ganze in ein schönes, verwendbares Produkt, was dann andere Leute auch einfach benutzen können. Wie zum Beispiel auch Linux-Distributionen, das einfach in ihre Paket-Manager mit einbauen, und somit kann es vom Administrator ganz einfach installiert werden.
Der Gedanke, den mich gerade treibt, ist, er wagt sich ja jetzt im Prinzip mit diesem Apache-Friends so an die Front, die die Entwickler immer nicht mögen. So echte Benutzer, Leute, die Fragen stellen, auf die man gar nicht kommen würde, und so weiter. Das ist ja eigentlich der Feind. Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Entwickler und End-User, das geht nicht zusammen, aber bei Open Source finde ich, hat das einfach noch mal eine ganz brutale Dimension manchmal. Weil da ist auch einfach Verachtung im Spiel und es geht gar nicht. Insofern finde ich das jetzt einfach sehr interessant. Du sprichst hier so ein bisschen mehr für die Foundation, die Graupärz-Graybeard-Foundation. Ich übertreibe das Beispiel jetzt, aber nicht wahr? Und du wendest dich halt an andere Sachen. Ich kann mir jetzt vorstellen, dass das sozusagen auch mal eine interessante Melange wäre, dass man eben genau diesen Erfahrungshorizont, was treibt denn die Leute da draußen? Was ist denn sozusagen der Schlüssel für Massenadoption von Technologie eigentlich? Das sind ja eigentlich so die interessanten Erfahrungen, die man eben genau diesen Projekten auch geben muss. Auch wenn die sich im Wesentlichen auf so einem Developer-Level machen. Aber manchmal sind es ja einfach nur Banalitäten. Wie muss Dokumentation gestrickt sein? Wie muss Software daherkommen, damit sie eben sozusagen schon beim ersten Auspacken einen gleichglücklich macht? Und man nicht gegen so fünf total vermeidbare Wendefälle. Du sagst schon, du kennst das Problem. Ich denke, das ist auch so eine Wechselwirkung, die einfach Developer-Communities generell zu Gute kommen können. Um dann einfach mehr so den Blick in die Realität, in die wahre Welt der Anwendung.
Da die meisten Entwickler gerade bei Apache häufig auch selbst Anwender sind, haben sie natürlich schon auch im Sinn, solche Fallstricke irgendwie zu umgehen oder die auch gut zu dokumentieren. Und gerade die Dokumentation vom Web-Server ist ja wirklich erstklassig in vielen Sprachen erhältlich. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir auch User-Listen. Sprich, wir bieten auch ein Forum bei Apache, wo sich User hinwenden können, wenn sie Fragen gestellt haben möchten oder Hilfe benötigen. Drumherum gibt es natürlich auch ein ganzes Ecosystem, die sich dafür bezahlen lassen, um verschiedene Fragen für Unternehmen zu lösen und damit ihr Geld zu verdienen. Auf der anderen Seite gebe ich dir recht, diese Wechselwirkung zwischen Anwender und Entwickler ist natürlich absolut wichtig, um herauszufinden, wohin muss es gehen oder was ist wichtig, wie ist die Adoption oder ja.
Vielleicht musst du die Apache Friends mal auf die Apache Contragen.
Oh ja, ich brauche Zeit. Ich brauche viel mehr Zeit, als ich habe. Aber was auf alle Fälle stimmt, die Dokumentation von der Apache Web Server ist wirklich hervorragend. Allgemein ist sie hervorragend, gerade für ein Open Source Projekt ist sie explizit hervorragend. Das ist wirklich perfekt, würde ich fast sagen. Das ist ganz wunderbar.
Aber die ist halt immer noch zu technisch für die Designer, die du vorhin erwähnt hattest.
Bei Apache Web Server geht es ein bisschen in Richtung Endanwender, würde ich sagen. Wo dieser Konflikt da ist, da haben wir schon einen wirklichen Endanwender. Ich habe wenig mit den anderen Produkten zu tun, aber wenn ich an Modper zum Beispiel denke, oder auch Spam Assassin, da ist die Berührung zum Endanwender noch ein bisschen geringer. Da wird es weniger Endanwender, ähnliche Leute geben, die damit zu tun haben, oder bei den anderen Produkten, die du beschrieben hast. Wenn es Library sind, ist der Endanwender auch gleichzeitig ein Entwickler. Da gibt es natürlich noch andere Ansprüche an die Dokumentation und an die Usability von Software.
Ja, Jungs, haben wir noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen, was ihr erwähnen wolltet? Wofür ihr geschlagen werdet, wenn ihr jetzt nach Hause kommt.
Ganz grundsätzlich noch mal erwähnen kann, ist, wie gesagt, Community Overcode zählt bei Apache. Also die Menschen sind wichtig. Die meisten der Mitglieder oder auch ganz normale Contributor, in Anführungszeichen, sind über die Jahre hinweg wunderbar gute Freunde geworden, gerade durch die Treffen auf solchen Konferenzen und Ähnliches. Und ich kann nur jeden herzlich einladen, mal reinzuschnuppern. Die meisten Mailinglisten oder 90% der Mailinglisten sind öffentlich und können durchsucht werden, können beobachtet werden. Und wir freuen uns auf jeden, der mitmachen möchte.
Das geht wahrscheinlich auch für dein Projekt, oder? Sucht ihr da noch Mitstreiter?
Wo wir auf alle Fälle Mitstreiter suchen, ist beim Support im Forum. Das ist eben sehr, sehr viel. Das ist viel Arbeit, da zu machen. Die Software letztendlich zusammenzuschnüren, ist auch viel Arbeit, aber relativ überschaubar. Das heißt, da brauchen wir eigentlich keine Unterstützung weiter. Aber der Support, das ist das, was wirklich zeitintensiv ist. Na gut, das kann man sich auch vorstellen.
Das kann man sich sehr gut vorstellen.
Man kann nicht alles mit FAQs abhanden, leider.
Gut, apache.org, apachefriends.org, das war's. Der Überblick über die Apache-Welt. Vielen Dank, Erik. Vielen Dank. Oder Oswald, je nachdem. Das war's. Chaosradio Express 148. Und ihr habt es euch schon gedacht, hier geht es wieder bald weiter mit einer neuen Ausgabe bei Chaosradio Express. Tschüss.